schönen guten morgen das ist bild live
an diesem mittwoch an dem wir den
mutmaßlichen mörder von eileen kennen
den jungen mann also der die 14 jährige
aus dem kleinen gottenheim in baden
württemberg getötet haben soll das ist
der mann der selbst schon mit 14 jahren
nur versucht hat ein mädchen zu
missbrauchen zu vergewaltigen was ist
das für ein typ was hat der für ein
leben gelebt da bild kennt die akte von
jan hajek kopie aus dem hessischen wald
sei es dem mutmaßlichen mörder von ali
29 jahre vorbestraft und mutmaßlicher
mörder der 14-jährigen eileen das junge
mädchen von diesem mann mutmaßlich
online geködert im auto verschleppt und
ermordet jan p kein unbekannter bei der
justiz was den anwohnern hier
aufgefallen ist sind gelbe briefe von
der staatsanwaltschaft die sich wohl
immer mal wieder an seinem briefkasten
gestapelt haben er soll vor langer zeit
schon den führerschein verloren haben
trotzdem aber immer mal wieder mit neuen
autos angefahren kommen sein doch die
weiteren verbrechen des 29-jährigen
mannes so viel verstörender als straff z
im jahr 2007 mit gerade einmal 14 jahren
begeht jan p seine erste straftat der
täter beging damals einen angriff von
hinten auf ein elfjähriges mädchen ein
gericht verurteilt den jugendlichen
damals zu sexuellem missbrauch
gefährlicher körperverletzung und
versuchter vergewaltigung seine strafe
zehn jahre in der
forensisch-psychiatrischen klinik
2017 endet der dortige aufenthalt mit 24
jahren wird jan p entlassen doch auf
antrag der staatsanwaltschaft kommt dann
ein überwachungsprogramm für
rückfallgefährdete
sexualstraftäter
am 25 januar dieses jahres endet das
programm jan p bekommt weiterhin
führungsaufsicht
die ermittler wissen jetzt es dauert
nicht lange bis der 29-jährige nach
seinem nächsten opfer sucht weniger als
sechs monate später verschwindet die
fahndung beginnt die ermittler werten
einließ online aktivitäten aus und
entdecken ein chat seit einigen wochen
mit einem unbekannten über das
onlinespiel fortnight also das größte
videospiel weltweit ziel dabei ist es
alle seine gegner zu töten als einziger
zu überleben während des games können
die spiele miteinander schreiben so auch
aline und ihr mutmaßlicher mörder jan p
die polizei ordnet das handy von
alliance chatpartner in der nacht von
alliance verschwinden lockt es sich am
teufelssee in hessen ein die ermittler
gehen inzwischen davon aus diese nacht
überlebt das 14 jährige mädchen nicht am
28 juli stürmt das sek
anwohner haben uns erzählt dass wohl
alle bewohner auf die knie gezwungen
wurden durchsucht wurden auf der suche
nach dem mutmaßlichen täter der sich
allerdings zu dem zeitpunkt nicht im
haus befand er wurde dann schlussendlich
in der gegend von frankfurt festgenommen
wo er wohl auf einem arbeitseinsatz war
er soll als wachmann gejobbt haben in
letzter zeit
parallel der grausame von palins leiche
im teufel sie seit einiger zeit treibt
sie bereits im seewasser jan p sitzt
seitdem in u haft und schweigt zu den
vorwürfen zu diesem grausamen mord
[Musik]